I'd like to introduce today's speaker
today's featured speaker is Olaf so
guard oliso guard is a professor of
Electrical Engineering at Stanford
University and the director of the
Edward Elkins sin laboratory he earned
his PhD degree from Stanford University
in 1992 where his doctoral dissertation
was the basis for the establishment of a
Silicon Valley firms silicon light
machines also known as MLM co-founded by
doctors Bogart in 1994 he was a postdoc
at UC Berkeley and in 1995 he joined the
electrical engineering faculty of the
University of California Davis his work
at UC Davis led to the invention of the
multi-wavelength fiber optical switch
which has been developed into commercial
products by several companies
professor Phil Garth research interests
include optical MEMS photonic crystals
atomic force microscopy and solar energy
conversion he has authored more than 300
technical publications and holds 50
patents he is a fellow of the optical
Society of America then Royal Norwegian
Society of sciences and Letters and the
Norwegian Academy of technological
sciences he certain he also serves as
the academic director for the new
Internet of Things graduate certificate
offered through the Sanford Center for
professional development which we will
we'll talk a little bit more about at
the end of the hour so now I'd like to
turn the floor over to Olaf thank you
very much Stephanie and thank you to all
of you out there who have logged on hear
me talk about things that are very dear
to my heart I've been working with
sensors for a long long time for smart
sensors is something that I'm very very
excited about they were happening for a
long time the internet to think this
newer but it also has changed how we
looked at sensors quite a bit and that's
part of what I'm going to be talking
about today so here's my outline I'm
going to talk a little bit about sensors
fundamental also because that allows you
to sort of understand a little bit
better is how you should design and
operate sensors in the internet of
things sort of environment and and I
will make the arguments an astronomer I
hope I make
argument that meant answers any
necessary made with silicon have found
these technologies and I'll talk a
little bit about what they are all the
ones that really are going to enable the
Internet and that has been doing so
obstinately will do even more of that in
the future and then I will towards dance
once we know sir when the students watch
the MEMS sensor is and what what it does
they'll talk a little bit about Internet
of Things and how it's going to be
enabled by BioMEMS dancers and I'll talk
with anybody watches the opportunities
that I see and you know really inviting
you to sort of think about what Internet
of Things can be for you in terms of
challenges and opportunities so that's
the worst the end but before I even jump
into the sensor part of it I just wanted
to say a few things about my perspective
on internet it takes an Internet the
things they're showing in here I say
pink cloud has many components to it
obviously the sensor sort that I have
the perspective from sensors but many
other people look at it from different
perspectives so you might be an expert
on the internet and how you used
Internet of course that's really the
backbones that ties everything together
machine learning and signal processing
and the far end it's also going to be
very important and many other
opportunities and challenges are there
circuits and embedded systems of the
things that are sort of takes the
sensors and connects them to the
Internet they say to think of it in this
way the sensors are the structures that
allows us to interact with the real
world and then we take it all the way to
the other and through them better
systems through the circuits through the
internet to the machine learning and
signal processing into the digital world
so the sensors are the interface if you
like and that's why I think there are
the most important which other people
are different perspectives on that but
there's some of the reasons why I think
sensors are so important to new centers
every day this is a two very very
incomplete less sort of sensors that you
use every day involved with sensors are
your cell phone in particular in the
neurotic strong letters in there those
are the ones that allows your screen to
rotate so the phone knows what what
orientation it is gyros do some of the
same things also complements your GPS
signals timing circus microphones light
sensors cameras all of these things
heartbeat sensors and proximity sensors
the heart rate sensor is the one that
sits in your Fitbit or sort of device
like that that people more and more are
using these days in your car you have
many many dozens of sensors and I'm
usually showing an incomplete list here
the next thing I wanted to do was to
talk about how sensors work and of
course if you look at this list and it's
just a partial list you will say that's
that's not a meaningful questions
because they're obviously worked in many
different ways and so I'll try to find
some commonality so I can say a few
things about how sensors should work and
how they should scale so let's take a
look at some of the ones that are out
there so this is Stanford work this is a
company called slide time what they do
is make clocks is actually so these are
clocks that are buried in your silicon
chip and and timing is of course super
important when you do communications or
four so this is the soccer stuff that
sits behind everything you do you use it
all the time you don't even know what
that there's really cool things about
this particular clock if you like if it
looks exactly like your grandfather's
watch at home in houses also later and
and the frequency of that oscillation is
what gives you the timing information
only this is a much more advanced thing
and much more stable thing and much
better in terms of keeping time than
your grandfather clock but we have here
is it if you look at them look at this
piece that is sort of you can see at the
cross-section here now I just say mass
that is suspended on the spring and it's
being driven and in a restaurant
frequent you'll talk a little bit more
moderate wrestling frequency it's in a
second but that need to be very very
well defined so that you can get a very
good time signal so this is the mass on
the spring essentially here's the here's
another example it's so much
gyroscopes they'd have several things
that I want to say about this this is an
airy complex structure the first I chose
was from Stanford this is from UC
Berkeley I don't want to be to stand for
something although you might feel that I
am around you when I go through this
slide this is from Berkeley in Perth the
part that the sensor is the gyro so this
is something that census rotation is so
similar to to their timing circuit I
just showed in the sense that is
essentially a mass suspended on the
spring and that's the center of it and
but it's also a whole lot more going on
here obviously there's some of my work
this is an atomic force microscope so
this allows us to sense things down to
the nanometer scale it may be as little
as one nanometer chips more trick with
your 10 nanometer resolution that's
wrote two different reactions here both
of them have this same thing there is
that if you look there is a spring and
there's some math associated with that
spring and and sort of at the end of the
spring and that allows us to vibrate if
you look at the one on the on the left
it sort of has a vibrating type of
structure that is like a in Canada or a
spring board the ones on the right is
more like a trampoline or something
that's actively in both cases you have a
spring and you have a mass suspended
from it and that's part of the important
operational characteristics of these
devices here's another one this is not
really a sensor but it's the type of
stuff that could go into a lidar for
instance this is the scanner you see
there's a mirror right there and that
mirror is rotating again it's a rotating
mass on a spring this is an upper soft
act they will sit in in future lidar
systems and we really try to miniaturize
goes and make them more efficient so
lidar is that the ranging systems and
imaging systems he used in self-driving
cars maybe the most famous example this
the Texas Instruments projection
technology they call it digital light
processing technology but that is it's a
little dude
mirrors and I one of them in the sensory
strips off here to show you they're sort
of substructure and that sucks or it's
very interesting but again it's a spring
that sort of the casinos little white
pieces those are Springs that connects
it to them there are in the mail rotates
on the spring underneath there's all
kinds of other things there is there is
integrated electronics in this between
the chip and that's a theme that I've
always turn to on location and so well
so again the obvious mass on the spring
here's what some of my works going way
back it's a cigar degrading light while
these are ribbons that move up and down
to create diffraction patterns that we
can use to modulate like that and then
also use them as sensors in different
configurations this is again certain
these ribbons have a mass they have a
spring constant air masses on the spring
so I think I'm trying to make their
arguments now that many sensors can be
shown what can be through describing
models as a mass on the springs and I
want to show you a little bit about how
that actually works this doesn't yet
give you a little bit of an over feels
for for how these type of sensors work
and also how they scale that's going to
be my main point right so here we see
sort of this is a very simple spring
board that I put together here in the
panel box is actually a hacksaw blade if
I engage it like that you can see that
is there vibrates at a frequency that's
the frequent reference frequency
resonance frequency is the frequency
where you have maximum energy storage in
terms of mechanical energy in this
system now it moves pretty fast there
now but it is already a sensor if I if I
think of this as a sensor right now of
course it's actually a accelerometer is
sitting in a extra is in an accelerating
field and it's bent a little that you
can't really see there very much
spending there and that's part of the
problem that you know you need to be
to measure how far it danced if I wanted
to use it as a make magnetic sensor
instead which I could do and then bring
this magnet in here and you can see that
it starts to bend it are you using
risers see up there is enough and and
now I actually have a better extra all
murdered and I had before at least it's
more sensitive now you can more easily
see that the events so now that even
with just eyeballing their seconds you
can see that that there is an
accelerating field this way that's why
if it was $10 instead you know that I
turn it upside down take a look at this
when I now engaged it I think that if
you remember back to weather and I did
it before it moves quite a bit faster
and then it does now so there there's
some things that happen to the fistic
shell when I make it more sensitive I
made it more sensitive to gravitational
field - just as a scale if you like a
little more more sensitive scale we're
more sensitive a barometer by doing this
they also made it slower and so that's
but the point that I want to make is
enough switch back to my slides here and
then you can see that what I showed you
is essentially a system that I've shown
here to figure there is a spring as a
spring constant
okay there's a mass that's moving on it
what I didn't show I didn't talk about
but this is some damping but you could
certainly see that the swinging didn't
go on forever so downtown maybe being
downside fast enough there I'm looking
at it over here over here now it's still
vibrating but is the vibration goes down
so there's a damper and then there is
something that we didn't really have in
our experiment so I asked you to just
eyeball how much they moved and that's
some kind of measurements for how much
the mass is actually displaced so if I
think of this as an extra matter if I
modeled and examined in this way then I
have a proof mass M that is going to be
displaced by acceleration so I
accelerate the whole system and get a
displacement of M that according to the
first that gives me a force and times a
and that has to equal the spring force
so I can calculate once I just measure
this displacement I can calculate the
acceleration that that the mass has been
next subject to by knowing the spring
constants measuring them displacement
and divided by the mass that's my
measurement and this is how it's actual
murders work this is how they work in
your phone this is how they work in your
car this is the exact mechanism that is
being used when it's in a given and here
bag deploys in your car so so we have to
sort of add a little bit more than just
a simple formula that tells us what
acceleration is if we have a certain
displacement we also have to realize
that there is a bandwidth associated
that we assured you that so that once I
made the displacement larger by putting
more mass on my my spring I had a slower
resonance frequency that's essentially
meaning that I can't measure signals
that are passed anymore I can only
measure slow things once I do that so
that's the trade-off the trade-offs he
is showing here but I should say one
thing first
what I asked you to do when we looked at
the video was to just eyeball and
displacements in mm sensor we don't even
do that we use some kind of electrical
characteristics to measure since it is
measure displacement and in our extra
matter we use the capacitive measurement
so this now you see that I have the same
system I had before that I added a
little bit I added a little circuit here
that just basically put voltage on this
plate across this through place so
there's a counter electrode down here
the mass has become a electrode and I
have an electric field here I can now
measure the distance between those two
plates by looking at the capacitance in
this circuit the capacitance between us
that's a very very good measurement I
can measure very very accurately this
way I mean my
much less like measuring distances
there's much smaller than the size of an
item with these upper techniques them so
and this is part of my sort of small is
beautiful argument I can really measure
very small displacements very accurately
with this technique if I want to measure
something that's large and moves a large
rare instance your cart putting up to a
up to a stop sign or a a traffic light
exercise and then you know you know that
after the what is to change that then is
measuring the position of your car
mathematically that's to long distance
or so but for small distances very
accurate measurements we use electric
field so once we have that you have this
measurement of precision Delta C and
anything calculated air acceleration
like I said and I can rewrite that in
terms of that formula that I showed you
for the reference frequency in this
right so here this is really if this
central design equation for an extra
meter and the Gorsuch I said it's not
only the exotic strawberries all these
other sensors and actuators too so let's
say that we wanted to now measure the
smallest possible acceleration in the
given bandwidth so you want to get grow
up to a certain frequency there are
certain signals that are so passes on
care but we do care about certain
signals up to a frequency s we could try
to make that happen by having a very low
spring concept and the very large mass
then I would get a strong signal
they also related very soul resonance
frequency and we do take a look at that
frequency Restless recursive definition
the gross has the square root or the
spring constants over the mass so so
that's that's attempt isn't very good
making it some a good answer by making
it very to reach spring and a large mass
well it sort of works but it doesn't
work for the frequencies are very
interested in but you can't try to do is
to make a miniaturized I saw a matter so
now we have a very small mass and maybe
also then compensate by making it very
week sprint so the ratio of the two that
is it's important to small it's okay
it's locates out a small mass because
you can also make it a weak spring and
still it remains in a good small
measurable acceleration so when it
really comes down to is to measure this
displacement Delta C very accurately I
asked you to just eyeball it that's not
going to be good enough using capacitors
you can measure that very very
accurately but the key there is to make
them small so we want small structures
because they are excellent position
sensitivity and you can this join them
throughout any resonance frequency we
want because it's a ratio of two
different sensors through their friends
quantities the spring constants on the
mass that matters these leaders too must
remain arguments over this last few
slide and you want to use miniaturized
answers anymore it's going to make them
as small as you can possibly make them
and that's where MEMS comes from M
stands for MEMS microelectromechanical
systems I said before these are systems
or sensors that are made using
integrated circuit technology this is
something that started their way back
and it's you know Stanford was very
central to it this isn't if some figures
from an article I read in 1983 when it
was published in Scientific American and
there's Jamie I'm angel Israel and the
other gentlemen on this paper were here
a staffer at the time and they did some
very very cool thing to wrote about this
gas chromatograph herbaceousness to
explain how that works
the attacher is not an example of
something that's there yes mass on the
spring it's a way for scale integration
it's not there basically measures the
composition of gases to gas mixtures
this one here at in the lower right hand
corner is an ox Rama turned and of
course here you can immediately
recognize the spring right there and the
masses all know that this is the spring
with a mass on it so this is exactly
like what I just showed you and
here's another one this is a a pressure
sensor if you're measuring just sort of
static static static pressures like in a
like if you're just trying to follow the
weather or something then maybe the the
resonance frequencies are important but
if you use something like this as the
microphone which people do now
increasingly and many of you have
discussed the microphones in your cell
phones and then again you have your
reference frequency as a key parameter
and you have the same sort of you have
the same arguments for making as small
as possible
this was an incredibly powerful article
for Mia this is where I did what I did
later three years after this came out I
was a staffer myself so and I did in
Norway when I read it so this was this
was sort of life-altering for me and the
other thing that came out a little bit
later was the part article by Kurt
Peterson and he the particulars figure
that I pulled out of that article he had
the articles or the publication was gold
silicon as a mechanical material and of
course that goes to the heart or what
I'm arguing to silicon it's really it's
that that is the best possible material
to make sense of sorrow he showed in and
I'm sort of reproducing that figure here
a piece of work that was done by a PhD
student here at Stanford Lawrence was
her name
and she made some of the first MEMS
accelerometers so these are basically
their forefathers if you like of their
accelerators that you have in your cell
phone and in your car right now this
structure you see they are in the groin
and of course you recognize if you look
at this structure that they have a
spring and improve mass exactly the same
thing as I've been talking about so and
when he makes MEMS we make a micro
electromechanical systems that we use
many materials essentially if you go
through the periodic table of the
elements here almost all of them must
been used in some fashion either for
fabricating maps or being part of mem
structures but they're really the most
important parts I'm not going to go
through the whole video
a large number of material savvy like to
use and that be a rotational use the
silicon is the main the main sort of
main state they want to use always and
the reason for that is that it's
stronger than steel lighter than
aluminum and it's single crystalline it
can also be used in poly crystalline
form the single crystal in particular
has some very very good properties and
there's no other mechanical material out
there that anywhere like it them if you
think about construction and so for
anything but steel maybe and it can be a
single crystal in the copper can be
single crystalline but they never are
and when you are talking about that
constructions only silicon this is
single crystalline in mechanical systems
and that's what makes it so unique is a
little bit about silicon it's a it's in
the group for in the periodic table of
the elements and therefore it has the
diamond like structure same as carbon
and each crystal Isis that means that
there are some certain planes within
silicon and that are more robust than
others if you expose it to a chemical
apps some planes just want s as well as
others and that means that you can make
structures like this so I'm showing you
some structures they are there you can
make very well-defined structures that
are exactly terminating on this one one
one place these crystalline planes that
are more robust than the other plans
and what that allows you to do is to
machine very accurately in parallel and
that's the key point you can make
machine in parallel you know to think
about a machine shop you have a machine
there you take a piece of aluminum piece
of steel and the machine as you do it at
one at a time you can go back to that
then that digital light processing
technology of Texas Instruments they
have a million little machines on a chip
you couldn't possibly make them one by
one so this idea of making them roll in
parallel making them by chemistry as
opposed to by machining machining by
chemistry if you like that's very
central in here so the starter that
and here are some of those typical
sensors so one of these that was very
popular for a long time was the use key
to resist their sensors to do the
measurements or displacement I chose
capacity before this is again from that
same paper that the that pressure sensor
in the lower right here is from that
Scientific American article by angel and
his coworkers so this is one example of
how you make the oppressor sense
pressure sensor that is actually not
capacitive in this particular case but
in use another transduction mechanism
one thing that made a huge impact on the
silicon valley was using these things
for inkjet not Sol so this is the the
basis of the transformation that
happened within HP user Packard when
they became sort of an printer company
for a few years
this is there's the heart of an inkjet
printer of course that was something
that maybe has come and gone but but it
was very very important for a long time
so this is about machining things out of
silicon are lots material that I think
so highly of another way of making micro
machines is to deposit layers on top of
silicon and then shave them and this is
the sort of canonical example of that is
it's a chrome drug that could be sitting
in something like a timing circuit or an
extra meter and in fact the that
particular technology has been taken to
extremes by by a number of companies and
also institutions around the United
States or Sandia in particular made it
very very sophisticated surface
micromachining process that you can make
almost anything in so and of course
surface micromachining is also the
underlying technology for that digital
light processing technology that I
already talked about a little bit
another aspect of fabrication asserts up
to
modern day micromachining and MEMS is
deep reactive ion etching some of the
most seminal work in deep reactive ion
etching for MEMS has also done here at
Stanford how it works is that they when
you try to accent to silicon tend to
sort of get shapes that are not
extracted ideal so if you take a look at
that cross-section in the upper left
hand corner I started to actually into
silicon I get these sort of slopes or
rounded sidewalls and what I can do then
what happens automatically in this
process I'm reacting right iron that she
said I deposit of polymer and then I
extra polymer at the bottom of that hole
I actually did a directional lash so
that the bottom is is that exposed and I
can repeat the process and like yet it's
dead or getting sort of a very large
sort of rounded sidewall I get a
sidewall that consists of some these
scallops little scallops then they can
be very very small so I essentially when
I've done this I keep repeating this
this deposit polymer then ash deposited
polymer then that process I get
something like what I've shown here in
the bottom the right-hand corner where I
basically get straight sidewalls that
this was a huge step forward because now
we could shape things differently now
you were no longer dependent on the
crystalline orientation of our silicon
die because shape is more arbitrarily
and so you can do things like I'm
showing here this is a very much used
type of wafer in MEMS its silicon on
insulator what it means is I have taking
a silicon wafer deposit is oxide on it
and then put a layer of silicon on top
of that oxide again so that's what I'm
showing on the top here and then we just
take that deep RIE and misshapes that
top layer into whatever we want and then
you remove the oxide from underneath
from where we want to that they are
freestanding structures so this is
essentially the the basis process for a
large number of MEMS devices and here so
sort of just one example this is this is
close to 20 years old not so it's not
sort of the modern type said necessarily
and
a couple of points I want to make here
is a very simple process therefore the
structure you see is made in one mask in
in an SOI wafer and it has very very
powerful functionality is actually a
fiber optics tricks this particular
example the point I'm going to make is
that it's way too large I thought said
that that MEMS the one of the
fundamental reasons to use maps and
particularly the Internet of Things says
we're gonna have so many sensors that
they have super small so so the question
is how do we take this up the
technologies I talked about the sort of
the chemical machining the surface
micromachining and the deep RIE how do
we combine those to make really small
sensors so that I think it's where the
futures are very very small sensors and
here's one example this is from my own
work where we have been able to put a
large number of the search
functionalities together this is an
atomic force microscope that is so small
that it sits on the facet of an optical
fiber an optical standard optical fibres
125 micron so that it'll be more than a
tenth of a millimeter in diameter and
the output a fully functional atomic
force microscope on top of it so that is
sort of a tour de force in fabrication
if you like it also shows that we now
the technology said to go smaller when
it key technologies behind that
particular development is shown here
that's hydrogen annealing so if you
start out with a piece of silicon and
you put it at low pressure in an
hydrogen ambient and eat it up a little
bit you will actually get sort of a
green confirmation of the silicon in
with flourish they'll stay in sort of a
single crystalline form but you can make
all kinds of very very interesting
devices what I'm showing here is on the
on the left or a photonic crystal on the
right I'm showing that how you can
actually use this to make voice I'm
going to
maybe more careful detail later one of
the picture in the lower left hand side
or no sorry in the lower right hand side
and it's one of my favorites because you
can actually see there in those words
that are created you can see the facets
the crystalline facets on the silligans
are showing that this is in K in fact
sort of a crystalline material and even
though these words show that very
quickly so so just to show you this is
what I think is the basis for a number
of sort of very important Memphis was
going for that sort of incense a
technology that allows you to make more
less arbitrary shapes of silicon and I'm
demonstrating that here so we start here
with a sort of following numerically
from one of the priests until it can be
deposited masking layer with powdering
something in today's in that Nam at the
level three and then the action to the
silicon so only one mask so far in that
practice can only be one mast then I
doing those tricks there in number five
I cover everything conformally with a
thin film and then in six stock
continued matrix I now remove things
from the bottom that's just it is sort
of an idea we got from the deep RIE
right I remove things from horizontal
surfaces the top surface doesn't matter
which is already covered by such a thick
passivating layer and then I go and I
actually bit further down into silicon
with a directional edge and in number
eight I can sort of complete the thing
with a weird a an isotropic a track
created spheres for me this the sphere a
spherical hollows and then I continue I
just do the same thing again in ionic X
direction and then be further down I do
the conformal coverage in tan I do the
removal from horizontal surfaces in
eleven I continue their chin trial I do
another this Sun much longer isotropic
etch in thirteen and then I remove all
the passivation in fourteen and I have
that structure and that you see they are
and then sort of the magic happens
because going from fourteen to fifteen
what I've done
it's a hydrogen and the other I have
reflow distilled again and that allows
me to make these very very complex
structure so maybe this is the
cross-section and sort of a cartoonish
things I want to show you some SEMS of
that same thing to really show you what
it looks like in real life so this is
before it's just a that this is at this
level 14 in the fabrication process yeah
baby now cut it out cut off so you can
see what it really looks like there is
this little hole down in the silicon
there's just there's a spherical balls
or partway down and then there's some
board
let's continuous that be stretches from
a hole to hold further down again at the
top which is just these cylindrical
holes and now then we do the magic like
I said now we do the hydrogen anneal and
then this is what happened so you can
now see that those spherical horse that
I had in the upper layer has turned into
voice and Andy actually the silicon
closed on top of them they closed
underneath them in the left two
structures in Lefty's boards and that
are separate and then when left a sort
of continuous void on the needs
now I really have this is actually a
very good pressure sensor we tested this
in many different designs because there
that them and that the shtetl of small
spherical voids on top it comes to a
photonic crystal that gives me higher
activities we actually use an optical
readouts and optically interferometric
readouts to make this into a very very
precise pressure sensor but the whole
structure is made right there and I
think that you would agree with me that
there is very few limitations on what I
can make in terms of shapes with this
and then really really nice thing about
it is that this our single crystalline
silicon and they're extremely small and
that's those two points hangs together
because by making things out of silicon
crystal crystalline silicon I can make
things very small and still have them be
very very robust
I can control the process better so I
can go to very thin films and so forth
so this is a very very powerful managed
technology here's I'm just showing a
simplification of what I just showed you
this time I forgot tannoy I forgot
go making that upper layer and I just
make a voice or you see down down there
instead I just made a voice this is a
pressure sensor by itself that the
diaphragm is now sitting on top of a
reference cavity there's actually very
little pressure inside of the voids that
are created because we do the reflow the
hydrogen on yield that's very low
pressures and then we end up with
something that's a very simplified
pressure sensor and simplification is
super important here I believe we need
to have things that are simple if you're
going to go to the internet settings so
that's why I love this particular
special accessories just silicon and it
has just avoiding it and I can read it
out to positively like we talked about
before how much stack of code I frame
has displayed what can measure it
optically there's a number of different
things I can do that but it's super
simple so that brings me to sort of the
point I want to make about smart sensors
since I've been working with like I said
you know in 1983 I got super excited
about maps and I decided to come to
Stanford to study that and work with
these people
I've never actually worked with your
main drill but it's like golf with him a
few times so so study with his
reinforcements upon so right now he was
a great great person when I work with
people here the MEMS and one the
conundrum search for MEMS is this idea
that is he making you know silicon we
should put some intelligence into the
sensor and I showed you example so that
already by the Texas Instruments a test
instrument technology there's there's a
set of switching capacitor switching
transistors underneath the mirrors that
I showed you and analog devices is the
company that us really made me run the
further in here in them in commercial
life saying capacity to the capacitive
accelerometers and gyros and they also
have integrated them and atronics on
chip and other examples of that there
are a few out there but not many because
it's very very difficult to do that so
when you're talking about the Internet
of Things where the sensors are going to
be
fikriye so you might actually have to
grow it much cheaper elderness anything
then you can get with this process
integration where you use Manson CMOS
together I don't believe that that is
going to drive drive the internet the
things I think that's what we really
have to do is to do what I'm saying at
the bottom to assemble things together
assembled electronics together with very
simple sensors to make this simple as
possible and devices and systems that we
can make so that's what brings me back
to the internet for things than they're
sort of like the proverbial elephant
internet so things that depends
completely on your perspective with what
part of the elephant to grab on to right
there I I'm sort of very enamored with
the sensors as you have understood I
think they are the most important part
but that's of course share my
perspective I think that that that's
where the real world meets the digital
world and that's why it's the most
importantly all the people said no no no
come on
the sensors have been around forever
what really new here is the Internet
than did the the machine learning and
then of course what's exciting is that
what what this can do for innovation and
so forth what you can do in big data and
and you know and then of course all the
people says no but really it's the most
important is how you implement all this
to the circus and embedded systems and
so forth so exactly what the Internet of
Things is and what's most important that
insight is sort of a nice question that
I can't answer and like my take is
either the sensors are the most
important door so they want to enable
things but I do think I can say a little
bit about opportunities and the cruel
applications so let me have a standby
that morning I think hear a lot about
this station and everybody is excited
about this autonomous vehicles
particularly cars but it also extends
the airplanes drones under water
exploration and the aerial mapping and
so forth so here I sort of I did my
little animation of that server right
now the way most autonomous vehicles
operate is that they have a lion
dollars.the stands for light detection
and range
and basic is what I'm showing as a laser
beam sort of scanning across the field
of you read missing things reacting so
it's almost like a camera there has a
little bit more information because it
can give you a little bit of most
information and so forth and it also has
maybe better resolution at a distance
but you're basically you're getting an
image of what's going on and that's not
what our eyes do when we are driving we
do something quite different they are we
are in the environment they don't
photograph it sort of with a certain
frame rate I mean watch the areas of
interest and you also are very good at
picking up emotion and that's what we
need to do in in sort of future
self-driving cars so here's sort of what
I think it should do you should be scan
across it should be take a look yeah oh
there comes a dog running I have to look
at it so that's what the human does it
doesn't look at the tree at all because
the trees the Mel age they topple over
that's the problem if they move but most
of it standing still they're going to
continue to stand still like the sort of
at least the assumption so this is a
real nurse it's really what the internet
to take this all about
even we are the environment them wanted
to do that to get that functionality I
just showed you
yes you space to race so this is one
possible solution we're working with
that do you have skype mechanisms that
allows you to jump to any sort of point
in your field of view not can sort of
like there will get the full picture at
the same time you're looking at exactly
what Excel what is important just like a
human would and that's where we're sort
of some of the advantages are going to
come in when you actually have a
self-driving car I do think that there's
a very good chance that it's going to
operate a little bit more like a human
in terms of what it actually senses and
what he pays attention to and that's
what this particular technology allows
you to do this is a man's face array I'm
not going to talk too much about how it
works but it's essentially the same kind
of structure again right Mouse on this
brick here's some other things that I
think they are super exciting visuals
very troubling in some sense you have
the arable sense is that not really a
big deal
everybody's wearing a Fitbit or
something like that these days
then you can ingest through diagnostic
devices in pills and so forth that's a
little bit more invasive and of course
I'm working in the in the horrible endow
this with implantable sensors so I did
what I'm showing here in the upper right
hand corner is an implantable microscope
that allows you to follow cancer
progression in an animal model so so
this is it's a sort of very invasive
they can also give you a lot of new
information and then the one on the
bottom bottom arises are certain
implantable microphone Asha said I
basically looked at as sort of acoustic
fields in the body and and how those
what they tell us about the different
diseases and so forth so these are very
very in exciting fields that really
really and even one of the people who
really goes into this establish a young
professor at approved who is actually
put together some on this slide and she
will she she it's in the process of
revolution I think this in making sort
of you know improving world aspect of it
and you will see more and more of this
and particularly sort of their
ingestible implantable sensors is just
starting out now so what this is what
they are and where and I think that we
can see more expect to see more than but
what are some of the challenges and
opportunities that that represent you're
gonna get just more and more health
records all of us then you need to
integrate that so you can really sort of
guess that's the important information
that's a big data problem and may be a
machine learning problem there security
of course is super important we don't
want people to hack our information but
here's another thing
I'm talking about here false positives
see if you have a sensor that tells you
that you might have a symptom that is
problematic then you go through your
doctor so the doctors off is going to be
full or healthy people but they are
anxious about some device that they have
that tell them something now that of
course if you ask doctors they will say
that's going to be a new problem it's
gonna be not married this is not going
to work but I know you can't turn that
around because there's an energy there
people care about their own health and
what we really need to get to is that
you don't really just go involved in
those doctors about false positives what
we do is that we have become an
assistant to the pro to the doctor so
somebody can actually work with the
doctor on the team and I think that the
Internet of Things and sort of there's
those medical sensors are going to help
us do that now so in terms of
opportunities if you can find a business
model that allows you to tap into that
energy that people have about caring
about their own health I think your
world win big I don't know how to do
that this is this has so many aspects to
it Assessors are only one of them so so
to end up them so what what do I see us
there big opportunities of Internet of
Things and what are you cool
applications I think that's internet so
things like I said even if I can't
really define it it's about awareness
that's really one way to if you want to
use one word that describes the
usefulness of the internet so thinks
it's awareness that's going to need to
efficiency safety sustainability in
transportation healthcare food you know
in production transportation storage
preparation you're going to get smart
cities smart homes and so we're getting
have a lot more awareness or what's
going on around ourselves you need to
talk to buy from a company partner of
yours or a sort of entrepreneurship
prime point of view there's going to be
a lot of people trying to develop the
business concepts around this so you
really have to be unique just have your
own secret sauce I think unique sensors
is easy for me
think about how you make the sensors
unique it's not that you couldn't
measure things I haven't been measured
before when you're going to use them in
different ways and you can integrate
them in different ways you're gonna
you're going to communicate with them in
different ways that's the uniqueness
that you and that you need to develop
you can also be unique on how you
execute that's a lot harder but it from
my point of view and we're of course
people are going to win their true part
of the execution is how you actually do
some of these things with the circus and
thereby the systems have better user
interface I think is super important
track we really need to solve the big
data problem by having machines take
that over and presents us with
information as opposed to data but maybe
the most exciting things about internet
the things that they can affect us in so
many positive ways if you work on this
you have sort of so many opportunities
to do good
now you also do rounds are okay but I
think that's doing good it's really
really what makes me excited about
things and other things so with that I'm
going to thank you for listening and I
hope that you have some questions and
you're gonna take those now I believe
yes I'll start by by the question about
limitations on miniaturization so the
question is is there any limitation for
miniaturization of men's cancers as the
structure reaches the nanoscale and
clearly there is this such limitation
there are such limits once you are
getting down towards the decisis that
are comparable to sort of atomic
distances or separation in silicon this
is a crystalline material with a very
distinct or very well-defined liquor
atomic distance between between the
nearest neighbors
what's your honor well once you start to
approach that of course everything that
I talked about becomes very different
things that we can just take many of the
concepts that we have made and scale
them down into the hundreds of
nanometers so it's made and maybe tens
of nanometers was smaller than that and
of course that's what we're electronics
already yes right so this the
manufacturing base for growing to those
the sizes are there we can grow there
when the technology has been developed
develop for for electronics and I have a
hard time seeing some sensors that where
the sort of the overall sensor is lesson
10 nanometers that would be crazy sounds
to me so so maybe somewhere in the tens
of nanometers where where the limits are
where we have to sort of start doing
things very differently yes so I think
that that's sort of answers that
question so the next question goes to
listing by the integration is it
possible to X MEMS sensors on the same
silicon die as an integrated circuits
and that it's possible and there are
many strong examples of that you know
and I keep bringing up this digital
noise processing technology or Texas
Instruments I think that's a tour de
force and technology development it has
some electronic sort of underneath an
alias bill MEMS on top so that's
definitely one example of that and and
there are several other companies has
done the same thing I think that to do
that if you look at the texas instrument
technology it's only rarely updated
because it's so difficult to do an off
state over technology like i took a long
time to develop i'm not going to try to
hazard a guess as to the total
development my dress betty was going to
be in the hundreds of millions and and
that means that only a few applications
can be reach can really have the
ambition to do something as complex as
that so I think that for most Internet
of Things sensors you will not do that
just simply because there are other ways
that are more cost-effective with the
type of diversity that they expect to
see in the internet of things and then
there's a couple of questions about
reliability in in so
just read a couple of the questions at
least one of the questions is there any
mechanical way around with time for MEMS
sensors and of course the answers you on
the page without this yesterday I take
some more things that and the next
question is along the same lines is that
that the MEMS currently undergo
extensive testing during manufacture
what's the current thinking on long-term
testing amounts that are in current
operation question goes to the
reliability factor so I'm just talking
about relatively reliable 'ti in general
first there there is a large number of
MEMS sensors out there actually we
expect two to reach two trillion sensors
a very small fraction then maybe one in
a thousand or 1/100 is going to be an
internet I think there's many systems
that aren't going to be connected a
lifestyle and and they are shown though
these sensors and we're talking about
billions of the knowledge Tronics
excellent reliability and it is
constraint because the smaller things
are they're more robust they are so and
of course then you also add that this is
the best material known to man in terms
of purity and it's pure clean crystal
it's a much more or less a crystal in
many cases long term stability is is
excellent for all Knapp's device let me
just take one sort of example I I it's
so much precision but if you take a BMW
with many people that say it's an OK car
right and you shake it and you'll find
out the first restaurant frequency
somewhere in the 10 servers that means
that is really not that good if you take
immense device and shake it and you try
to look for their first resonant
frequency it might be in the millions of
Hertz in the mega Hertz were leading to
hundreds of killers basically what I'm
saying is that any man survives for any
good well define divine design and
survives it's something on the order of
ten thousand three hundred thousand
talks sometimes more reliable
BMW now I am being facetious here but it
does go to this reliability now there
were some more specific questions in
there had to do with how it test and
that is difficult I think that there is
clear that there isn't other things it's
such an explosive growth as they are
going to not test enough for some of
these applications
I mean like you have to do more testing
as a general rule I think that math is
very reliable there of course you have
to test for it the next question has to
do with something that didn't touch on
that ball and that is but how do you
power the sensor so the question is
about energy harvesting methods or there
are any men sensors that can be self
powered by harboring harvesting ambient
energy and and again this is a big field
I didn't talk about it it's very very
important if you're gonna have sensors
every we are having bad races course
possible some of these sensors are using
very little energy and you can wake them
up only occasionally when you need to
read their data and I could get you into
very very small sort of power through
average powers so you might be able to
only even very small batteries operate
for ten years but of course what's
alluded to here well energy harvesting
is also very very interesting so the
most obvious is use solar cells and
things of that nature if you're
operating in an environment without
makes that's even an indoor environment
has a lot of lot of light energy
typically so you can combine that with
sort of a rechargeable battery you can
have something that essentially lasts
forever so you put that in quotes
because nothing lasts forever but at
least you don't have sort of a power
lifetime that's all here so there's also
a number of developments that goes to
things like get extracting energy from
vibration and so for you can think of it
if you have a pressure sensor in a car
tire and that's more and more common
these days so that you know whether you
actually have a problem with your with
your tires you don't really want to have
a battery in there but there's also a
lot nature high under the environment
because all the rotation
so you should be able to you might have
a value but it's a rechargeable battery
that's recharges through that energy
that you can extract from the rotation
that's going on so and if you're
harvesting matter is this
super-important and you saying that the
MEMS sensors are self-powering that's
like a different question no bits now
you're talking about the sensor itself
being that energy harvester - and my
general feeling there is that's better
to separate those two functions into two
different devices and put them together
into a real functioning system so we're
at the top of the hour so to be
thoughtful that run time why don't you
take two more questions okay yeah so so
let's see the next one I haven't read
yet Silesia
reality reader jobs now how do you see
IOT devices catching brain waves cell
metabolism and health in deep learning
this disease prevention of their bodies
yours that's actually more than one
question I think but there let me trust
it to stop that guy said it yes
definitely and I did mention it a Funes
ones are sort of premier researchers in
this field
lots of people are interested in in
Neurology and they're using Boros sort
of foster genetics and also a number of
different kinds of probes some of them
are made that are based on MEMS
technology so the brain makes it sort of
a little bit of a nebulous for me but
neurology and sort of action potentials
and things of that nature are being
measured with sensors and they will be
poured into those things at some point
although that knowledge what muscle is
very very invasive so exactly when that
kind of data will be part of the
Internet of Things it's not obvious to
me some metabolism and so forth that is
you know something that is much more
straightforward and you will do we have
quite a few sensors that are sore
in a micro fluidic systems where we do
and do all kinds of things like drug
discovery and so forth and there's a
large number of large number of MEMS
sensors yeah deep learning in your
courses I think this is during
disconnected from the first part of the
question deep learning is a super
important part of the Internet of Things
I just mentioned machine learning deep
learning is a variation on that I'm not
going to go into the details of the
differences but the deep learning is is
absolutely essential for dealing with
that we're the big data that we're gonna
get from all these sensors and it's not
for the questions you know progress is
playing to disease prevention and other
bodies you're having more data must help
but it's not obvious how you do that so
this is really one of the key questions
and really maybe want to see challenges
or we to turn around key opportunities
of how do we actually use more data to
make health care more efficient and
hopefully also less expensive and also
have better outcomes not obvious that
that's going to happen
and doctors are petrified of it yeah so
so I'll take the last question I'm
concerned about people hacking into
self-driving cars
another large object across harm what
are the safeguards this is of course
very well founded fear because I did it
said there has been examples already of
course being hacked into and people if
they were malicious I think most example
to be heard about how people doing this
for demonstration where they could have
done things like lock the wheel and
select our speed this is definitely
dangerous territory and I what's the
safeguards are this we have this game
this is actually something else needs to
be studied very carefully now it's
happened
take this Australian car as an example I
say that you have to be aggressive in a
employing them even if if in spite of
the fact that I really don't have a good
answer to this question and the reason
roughly speaking and 40,000 people die
in traffic in the United States every
year if we can reduce that number
substantially and even if you are
opening ourselves up for for malicious
hacking if the total outcome is likely
reduce that number substantially and you
have to go for it that's why I think
they have to be aggressive but
destruction of course points to some of
the most frightening things that around
the world Internet of Things and I don't
know what the saw scars are other than
being very vigilant and being having
sort of making the systems as hack-proof
as possible and it's young New York
ability certain certain New South Leslie
we don't even have a half proof
electoral system in this country right
so it's it's very it's a very tough
question and I don't really know the
answer in some cases we have to go
forward without being 100% secure
in other cases the downside is so huge
that we just basically cannot take the
risk so that's maybe maybe want to
answer the question is I mean we
basically have to parse the risk reward
and you grow forever very next up it's
great Thank You Olaf so much for a
wonderful presentation for taking time
to answer all these attendee questions
never manually we even couldn't get you
which shows me how much interest there
is in this field a reminder to all the
attendees recording will be made
available within a week and sent out to
those who registered and we just want to
thank you thank you so much for taking
the time to attend today and we'll see
you at our next webinar and hopefully in
our Internet of Things graduate
certificate as well thanks so much